when we talk about reprogramming I think
the the important thing to understand is
99.9 of what we think what we feel and
what we do although most people think
I'm in control I'm the one doing it it's
really non-conscious patterns that are
repeating themselves over and over again
when you and I were born the only neural
networks that we had were for survival
we didn't have any beliefs of are we
good enough are we smart enough we
didn't have any experiences to show us
that that's a scary situation that one's
not snakes are safe or snakes are
dangerous or spiders so over the course
of the first seven to ten years of our
life our brain's plasticity switch our
brains switch that connects all of these
neurons and creates the neural map in
our brain is being created in the form
of millions of connections per second by
time we're 10 or 12 years old that
switch basically goes off and now
there's more selective creation of
neural patterns based on what we like
what we dislike we're just an empty Open
Nest where everything's being formulated
and so what happens is after 10 12 years
old we're pretty much running on
autopilot and we become conditioned or
trained to see the world a certain way
to feel certain things to behave in
certain ways most of our life we're
working on autopilot because the
non-conscious processing parts of our
brain is working at you know 400 billion
bits of information per second and
trillions of electrical and chemical
reactions per second happy without our
thinking about it for adults you know 25
35 45 50
we have these patterns that we have to
revamp almost like a remodeling of our
own brains if you think about you know
when you're driving in a town that you
know whether you're at home or in your
city that you know and all of a sudden
you see a detour if you take a detour
and then you start driving down that new
DeTour for a day seven days two weeks
three weeks four weeks that detour
becomes the new easy road to take even
though you're used to going a certain
way the brain works the exact same way
so if you've got these patterns that are
easy for you your brain wants to take
those patterns that are easy for easy
thinking patterns easy emotional
patterns easy behavioral patterns why
number one because it's less energy that
the brain needs to to use so law of best
use of energy in the brain is where it
goes first
so the way you retrain your brain using
for example the 4r process is you
recognize my patterns of thought my
patterns of emotion my patterns of
behaviors and yourself are these going
to help me achieve the goal that I want
to achieve whatever the goal is it's
just yes or no if they are great
if they're not then what you want to be
doing is saying okay how do I change
that path how do I change my thinking I
think we play small by default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we have it
trained in US
from a young age our parents our family
our friends our teachers think about who
did you learn about life from probably
people who didn't like their own life
you know who did you learn about careers
from probably people who did not have a
great career you know who barely are
enjoying what they're doing in their
work and they're living in scarcity
mindset of this is all I can do and
that's what we've learned from and you
know guidance counselors at school do
they love what they're doing I mean I
think this is a huge problem and we're
stuck living small and living scared and
living as a result way below our
potential of what we could do and who we
could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problems when I wake up every day trying
to do trying to help trying to create
and so how do you how do you get out of
it well I think the starting point is
being around the people who are living
and doing the things that you want to do
I think the way to 10x your results is
not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverages busting through limiting
beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working
harder working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wins without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
never accomplish their goals who don't
end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both and so
if you're not working hard then you
don't have a shot but assuming you are
working hard and you want a 10x again
then it's a shift in mindset and a shift
in living beliefs so how do you identify
the living beliefs how do you figure out
where it's holding your back how do you
break through the Paradigm and hit a new
level a lot of it is environmental you
know the the current thinking that you
have was environmental it's your parents
and your family and your guidance
counselor and teachers and family Etc
that's environmental you've adopted
their beliefs and unfortunately a lot of
them are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably some that a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever is more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people every day but
you know we can't so how do you do it
well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
I think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter and when somebody
asked me yesterday on Instagram do I
think Elon Musk will buy Twitter
I said no I don't think he'll buy
Twitter but it's probably not a good
idea to underestimate Elon Musk
General right
you know lots of people have
underestimated him and he's proven them
wrong many many many times and I just
like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk it logically be
thinking through it if you're if you
were running Tesla uh in SpaceX would
you have thought about buying Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between small thinking and
expansive thinking like in his world it
makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks so much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at the hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if you
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles in his early life and he if he
can overcome that to get to where he's
at I see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove but the groove can also be a
rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expansive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors is what I call them an Elon Musk
a John Assaraf Oprah Winfrey people who
who you may never meet but you can still
learn a heck of a lot from step two is
to then try to go to some events that
change up your environment right if
we're a product of our environment then
if you're always stuck in the same habit
the same house the same routine the same
environment then it's going to constrict
the thinking have you ever noticed when
you go on vacation you come up with some
great ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but but what are
some changes you can make to your
environment what are some conferences or
events you can go to to be around the
people who think the way that you want
to think to inject some newness some
creativity some ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you're in that things that used to
make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation
competent event you come back to God I
wanna you ever gone away and come back
and want it to be
from person wanted to be working on new
projects new goals come with new ideas I
get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just think about if you're
just constantly stuck it doesn't mean
you have to go travel on vacation it may
mean you take up salsa dancing it may
mean you try a new hobby take that idea
that you've got and just go go to it
look at any events that are happening in
your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think of
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use uh
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful uh computer at the time with
with unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forward to only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class at you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at but he
wouldn't have known that unless he
dropped out of school and dropped in on
the calligraphy class so it's changing
the environments being a part of new
things it's it's not just staying stuck
in the same habit the same routines and
and same thing you're doing constantly
and that will inject newness that will
then allow you to be more creative and
create amazing opportunities for your
next goals so step one is to be around
aspirational mentors to be around the
people like an Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey
Etc watching videos content interviews
podcasts books that make you feel better
stronger more courageous step two is to
get out of your comfort zone and go go
to things physical things travel more
take take on classes say yes go to
conferences and events just so that you
expose yourself to new ideas and
opportunities and come up with fresher
ideas of what you could do with your
life and step three is to to actually
have humans in your life who you're
around who make you want to push and do
more and be better and this mean I hey
if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
mover makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know it's not Movie
Maker is something else but being around
other people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had
business partners I guess but I felt
isolated felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really struggled so find other
people who are on this journey that you
can do it with because when you feel
like you're doing it with other people
and you're not alone you'll be a lot
more productive a lot more effective and
have a lot more fun as well
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I started eating organic food several
years ago not 100 probably about 85
percent
um I became a vegan uh eight and a half
years ago or so nine years ago actually
in July it'll be nine years so I eat um
a plant-based diet and so uh why uh
easier for digestion for me
um organic foods that have all the
colors you know the phyto
phytonutrients Reds greens yellows Blues
purples
um I want all of the different
phytonutrients that are alive you know
in my opinion and in my research the
more food that we eat that's alive
um the more nutritionally dense it is
for us with the the vitamins the
minerals that we need the fiber that we
need for elimination the probiotics that
we need you know the gut bacteria the
gut microbe um has been studied for
quite some time but it really in the
last four or five years it's really been
an explosion of people talking about
your gut microbe right uh that uh the
you you've got obviously your brain you
know the uh I guess the head honcho uh
but you've got your heart as well and
the uh intelligence of the heart and the
Brain part but also your gut and so if
you're feeding your gut with prebiotics
and probiotics right that gives your gut
the ability the uh trillions of cells in
our body and the hundreds of millions of
hundreds of billions of gut bacteria uh
gives them the food that they need to do
what they do so are you focusing on your
gut health setting goals is an
intellectual and imagine exercise that
your conscious brain right I'm going to
show you one of the little brains today
from the city hall Mass you're your
conscious brain left prefrontal cortex
specifically where you get to choose
what is it you would love to have your
life be like what is the imagination you
know of the ideal life that you'd like
it says everybody could do that he says
but achieving goals
happens as a result of having the right
beliefs perceptions habits attitudes at
the non-conscious level
where all of the habits reside part of
the hippocampus part of your brain that
drives your automatic Behavior day in
and day out is what is going to
determine whether you achieve those
goals or not he says using willpower
to achieve goals
is like using gunpowder it's just a
starter using resilience or using your
imagination those are all really good
conscious abilities that anybody can use
he says but if you don't develop
the habits at the non-conscious level
which include your self-image for how
you see your life you're never going to
achieve those goals when I was
um five six seven years old I moved from
Israel to Montreal I spoke Hebrew but
not English or French and for two and a
half years I felt dumb I felt like I
wasn't smart enough and I wasn't good
enough and I was made fun of as a kid
that led to me being involved in street
gangs from the age of 12 to 16 in
Montreal in Montreal wow
we traffic drugs from Florida we did
break-in entries we we had a little
streaking about 12 of us that just got
into a lot of trouble my path was either
jail or the morgue one of the two and uh
there's a lot of successful people that
have that kind of a story for some
strange reason
um and at 19 I met a mentor his name was
Alan Brown he was a real estate
developer still in Montreal uh no this
was in I moved from Montreal after years
of turbulence I finally broke free and
moved from Montreal to Toronto which is
about 350 miles in Canada yeah and um
May 1980 I took my real estate course
June 20th 1980 became licenses of real
estate and the reason I did is I met a
man the weekend before that my brother
introduced me to
who was interpersonal development and he
was into you know Zig Ziglar and Dennis
waitley and Brian Tracy's you know 35
years ago and he introduced me to this
world of of you know the Mind
introducing me the world of changing my
beliefs changing my habits changing my
perceptions of first who are you and he
really helped me see that you know the
spiritual greatness within everybody the
intelligence that's within everybody had
me start with getting in touch with that
and it was very philosophical and didn't
have the evidence that we have today on
affirmations visualization meditation
mindfulness subliminal programming habit
Creation in all of the different
methodologies that we've all heard about
whether it was the astronauts that went
to the moon initially that trained their
brains or the musicians that have or the
athletes that do the science now is just
so phenomenal on what is actually
happening and so as I was building my
own companies I built my companies by
training my employees not on the skills
that they needed but on how spectacular
they were as human beings and the
greatness was within them and if they
trained their brain to have the belief
that is they may not have the skill or
the know-how but if you have the belief
that I can I will I must you can build
if you think about this I don't care if
you if we asked any question on health
wealth relations career business
spirituality we wanted to find the
answer to something yeah we could Google
it and within minutes have everything we
want to know tutorials videos audios how
to step-by-step blueprint color
coordinate whatever you want so our
problem isn't how to all the how to
exists how to build a business exists
how to be a great lover exists you know
it all exists how to get in shape right
so I wanted to focus on you know how do
I help more people take more of the
action they know they should be and want
to we have this phenomenal brain right
it's it's it's genius abilities we can't
figure out how to replicate it anywhere
with billions of dollars
but we are getting some of the user's
manual now so when you feel fear what
should you do I teach the first two
inner sizes that I teach every one of
our students number one is called take
six calm the circuits so if you have
this unpleasant anxious fearful emotion
energy in motion
right and it's unpleasant and the breaks
have gone on if you just take six deep
breaths in through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
breathing through a straw you will
deactivate the stress response Center
which means blood is going to go back to
the left prefrontal cortex the Einstein
part of the brain can actually think
through this problem because what
happens when the stress response Center
is activated blood goes away from that
into the fear response so you have
epinephrine cortisol adrenaline to be
able to get you out of this situation
it's part of our instinctual brain part
of The Reptilian Brain the first part of
the brain that was developed was that
then the mammalian brain the limbic
system then the neocortex the thinking
brain so when our brain has this signal
of oh my God you might get hurt you
might lose this you might get in trouble
you might be embarrassed to shame
ridiculed judged Etc that part of the
brain is going to get activated so if
you take six deep breaths first calm
down calm the circuits first
then do inner size number two is called
Aya AIA the first A is for awareness
what am I thinking right now what am I
feeling right now what am I sensing
right now what is my behavior right now
so you thoughts feelings Sensations
awareness of behavior what's my
intention right now that's the eye
well my intentions to move forward I
want to do this
great what's one very small action step
that you can take
now the reason you want to take one
small action step
is one small action step your brain can
handle
if it's one small step towards it the
threat response goes away
but if you focus on the end game right
away
you're going to get that rush and that
instant trigger of the fear response
stress response so the first thing you
want to do is learn how to manage your
mindset
and what you focus on learn how to
manage your emotions because they drive
your behavior more than anything else
because we move away from Pain and we
move towards pleasure but we move away
from Pain a thousand times faster and
pain wires in the brain faster for
survival mechanisms so purely from a
neuroscience perspective just
understanding self once you understand
okay this feeling is normal okay what
should I do
take six calm the circuits
Aya
and now you can start being Progressive
and make progress towards what you want
are you interested
in achieving that vision for your life
are you interested in achieving those
goals or are you committed
are you interested or are you committed
and I didn't know what the difference
really was at the time and so I asked Mr
Brown what's the difference and he said
to me says if you're interested you'll
do what's convenient if you're
interested you'll use the fact that you
didn't like school and you didn't do
well in school to control your thinking
and your self-esteem you said if you're
interested you come up with stories and
excuses why you can't achieve those
goals and dreams that you shared with me
you come up with stories and excuses as
to why you don't want to do the work
necessary to grow and to learn what you
need to learn
he says however
if you are committed he says you will do
whatever it takes you will upgrade your
knowledge you'll upgrade your skills
you'll become who you need to become and
you'll learn from whoever you need to
learn to be able to achieve those goals
and dreams so lesson number one
is no matter what goal or Vision you
have
ask yourself that question okay are you
interested in achieving that goal and
dream
or are you really really really
committed and willing to do whatever it
takes in many cases with adults we have
to unlearn which we learn the best well
we learned in the past and one of my
friends wrote a really good book is what
got you here won't get you there
so if
yeah if you want to achieve another
result that you've never achieved before
who is he
Marshall Goldsmith okay I see yeah and
um wonderful wonderful man and so if we
want to achieve another result that
we've never achieved before then we have
to become somebody different
we have to upgrade our skills we have to
upgrade our behaviors we have to master
our emotions better because we're going
to meet resistance yes and we don't like
change the human brain and body doesn't
like change I've said for 30 years now
the only human being that likes change
is a baby with a wet diaper
yeah that's the only human being that
likes change everybody else likes I like
everything just the way it is yeah and
so and as we get older
it becomes harder and harder to change
because the patterns in the brain are so
strong if you think about an oak tree
yes and if you looked underneath the
ground to the root system it's connected
to all the other oak trees maybe for
miles around all interconnected
it's hard to change it because you can
pull the oak tree but you still have all
the roots that are connected and if you
had a little baby tree that's maybe been
there for one year it's much easier to
go in yeah and pull the tree out and
take the root system out
and so as we get older we become more
and more conditioned to be more and more
the same
so it's not that change isn't possible
it's most people aren't willing to
commit
to switching from what's comfortable to
what's not long enough
for the new to be comfortable while
you're in the you know in the uh what am
I thinking feeling it's a chance to be
aware and the biggest gift we have as
human beings is our awareness because
awareness is what gives you choice and
choice is what gives you Freedom most
people are living their lives in a
reactive State automatic reactive State
because of these set points that we
start talking about so we're in this
repetitive cycle over and over and over
and over we react to the same things we
behave the same way we eat the same
Foods we dress the same way just to
maintain that homeostasis and comfort
zones and we've never been taught like
when were we taught as kids like here
are your six core emotions
here's the way you deactivate you know
your stress Center or fear so here's how
you activate your imagination Center
here's how you have more Focus here's
how you develop a new belief here's how
you develop a new habit here's how you
release one we haven't been taught that
we've been told they're important things
but we haven't been given the tools and
then we haven't practiced the tools
enough to be able to make them part of
our unconscious competence brain we
started to retrain our agents brains
after we did a we did a uh an event
75 agents paid I think it was two or
three thousand dollars to go through a
six-month brain retraining program those
75 agents increased our sales by 100
million dollars wow and we said okay
we're going to teach this to the entire
company yeah so we went from a billion
two to four point five billion in sales
a year in three years
by working on this versus what they
needed to do what you'll see is just
patterns patterns and more patterns the
entire universe is made up of patterns
that can be explained mathematically for
the most part but we can also just see
behaviors and so there it's not it's not
difficult
but it's it's it's it takes effort
to be able to override some of the
natural you know brains propensity the
brain's desire to keep us away from
hurting ourselves to re-educate our
brain yeah and if you think about you
know when we have when we when we're
young what our parents do well be
careful oh don't fall down oh watch out
how you ride the bicycle you know and if
you fall down well my kids when you know
when they were young I let them fall and
I let them do things so that they would
get accustomed get up
I wouldn't go and and and and you know
um baby them
it did fall down I was like great you
fell down get back up because they
learned that it's okay yeah most kids
when they fall down they'll look at an
adult to see well is the gay or not it's
okay or not and usually the adults are
either gonna baby them and and over
compensate or they're gonna look at them
says come on get up and and and and you
know do what you need to do think about
what is a belief and let's go to again
I'd like to just like to go to the
Neuroscience Fields because just my
passion now is a belief is nothing more
than a group of cells that have been
connected and then reinforced and we
have two types of beliefs we have
beliefs that what I really fast I'm
gonna stop you there because that's so
important yeah and so different than I
would have expected I think when people
hear belief it is believe in something
that is true which did not enter into
your definition
no we we believe whatever we believe is
truth for us but it's not the truth
that's really interesting right but we
have been conditioned
if we go back a little bit to
um what we talked about earlier about
you know when you were a baby when you
were born what belief did you have
zero goose egg zero not one and so you
learned what to believe and how to even
formulate your beliefs chances are from
parents
teachers brothers sisters television
maybe when you read some books right and
we behave based on what we believe
so we might be behaving our lives away
based on false or inaccurate or
disempowering beliefs
so if a belief is a neural pattern in
the brain
then we probably have some good ones
empowering ones useful ones and chances
are we have some that are not useful not
empowering and not worthy of the
Geniuses that we all are
so the question is is it possible for me
to develop new beliefs that I don't
believe right now well the key factors
to becoming a loser let's imagine that
together we build the training to help
people become a loser yeah repeatedly
thinking feeling and doing the wrong
things
every day okay great things okay do you
have another one hanging around with the
wrong people your environment is it
working your environment shapes who you
are okay very very much when I was
getting into trouble as a Young Man the
people that I was hanging around with
were also getting into trouble when I
was a little boy I remember my father he
used to tell me he says show me who your
friends are and I'll tell you who you
are yeah and so you're gonna be
the sum of the people that you invest
the most amount of time with
whether it's at home your friends your
family or your business people so if you
tend to be around winners
you'll start to buy buy sheer
environmental factors listen and learn
how they think you'll be able to observe
what they do you'll learn the skills
that they've Acquired and if you hang
around with losers you'll see patterns
everything in life is about a pattern
and so people who are unsuccessful and
losers which I don't even like to use
the the the term loser although there
are some not a lot
um they have got habitual patterns of
Destruction
self-sabotaging thoughts and
self-sabotaging behaviors
and people who are successful and I
don't mean just financially people who
are successful in their health their
relationships charitable contributions
they have consistent successful patterns
that are constructive towards being
successful after I you know got to real
estate then I traveled the world I um I
end up buying the franchising rights for
Re Max for the state of Indiana
and I was 26 years old and I bought the
franchising rights for Indiana moved to
Indiana and I remember being interviewed
for the Indianapolis Business Journal
and the guy said what are your goals
here in Indiana
26 years old I was wearing you know I
remember a brown pinstripe suit I had
glasses on even though I didn't need
glasses I just want to look older and I
said we'll do a billion dollars in sales
in Indiana and the gentleman said to me
says are you
um certain of that I said well that's my
goal he says well there are two largest
companies have been here for a hundred
years don't do 100 million dollars 100
our billion dollars combined and my
cocky young self I said well God first
just three weeks later the Indianapolis
Business Journal and I have it at home
it says sets one billion dollar goal wow
um May 1992 we hit a billion dollars in
sales five years later one of the things
that I was taught
playing sports was repetition is the
mother of skill repetition is the mother
of skill which is another lesson that I
learned at a very young age why does any
piano coach guitar coach
for sports have their students repeat
drills over and over and over and over
again whether it's layups or free throws
or playing you know certain chords on
the guitar or on the piano why is
repetition so important
the answer is because when you repeat a
pattern over and over and over again
whether it's a language pattern an
emotional pattern or a behavioral
pattern when you repeat it over and over
and over and over again 20 times 50
times 100 times 200 times 500 times a
thousand times you actually are creating
patterns in the brain that initially go
from being conscious patterns patterns
that require effort and intention and
attention your conscious mind to
patterns that become non-conscious that
require less energy and less attention
because it's been repeated so many times
it becomes second nature so you have to
use intrinsic and extrinsic motivation
so you have to
start everybody off well why is it
important for you to be able to develop
these new beliefs like what will your
life be like if you had them right now
what would your family life be like you
have to give them a benefit that's
greater than the switch cost
right so the switch cost is something
that our brain resists the only human
that likes change is a wet baby
every other human being is resistant to
it because Safety First and homeostasis
and energy conservation so we are
biologically wired not to want to change
so we have to deliberately coax the
brain into motivational reasons
emotional reasons you have to have
intrinsic reasons of why must you do
this
and so you can use pain as a frame as
well so if you don't then are you okay
with your life being like this at this
stage in five years and 10 years and 20
years
and if you're okay with that then you're
you're not a candidate for change but if
you're committed to letting go of the
old so you can create the new
and you create motivations every day
that's where the power is remember
earlier progress not Perfection so
anybody can do one minute or 10 seconds
so if you can start to formulate a habit
a daily habit a weekly habit it doesn't
matter how long it is if you can create
that space in your brain that on this
day at this time this is what I do and
you do that repeatedly that becomes a
habit and it takes those 66 days or so
for a simple habit that you have to
consciously do to then the Habit doing
you for the last you know 35 years you
know what I've been doing is I've had
coaches for skill training I've had
coaches and mentors for mindset training
I've had coaches on brain training I've
had coaches for business skills and
training I've had coaches and mentors
and experts for every different area of
my life whether it's Health Nutrition
business money investing getting out of
debt making more money protecting your
assets there are experts for every
single area of Our Lives that already
know what you need to do a lot of people
are stressed right now why text phone
mobile radio TV Facebook Twitter all
this it's just non-stop stress in the
brain and when the brain feels stressed
then obviously cortisone cortisone
cortisol epinephrine norepinephrine kick
in and that's a stress hormone well it's
like having you know your finger on the
electricity button all day long and just
not not stopping so you start to burn
the fibers your nerves if you're
gonna be uncomfortable your reward has
to be big yeah I think so so if you're
going to be making a change ask yourself
why is
what I want to achieve so important to
me why am I willing to to you know use
my new you know willpower persistence
and why am I willing to go through the
discomfort of change why am I willing to
you know listen to the negative talk
that I have or the emotion that I have
and still do it anyway
and if you don't have a big enough
reason
the first time you have a chance for an
excuse you'll take it and that's why
people they start on diets and after a
day or a week or two weeks they're off
the diet or they say you know what I'm
not happy in my relationship and you
know two weeks later they're back with
the same person or they find another
person just like the one that they left
or people are afraid to leave their jobs
because they don't like the discomfort
of change yeah well the only
certain thing in the universe the only
constant is change yeah every time
change everything that's the only
constant in the universe it's oxymoron
it's like how can change be the only
constant the only stable thing because
everything's changing so why not acquire
the skill to change everything to be
comfortable
and change and in today's era to be
comfortable within income funds yes yes
yes and so I know that the meaning that
I give remember I said you have to
reframe things yes the meaning I give
things now is when I'm uncomfortable I'm
changing and I'm growing and I go yeah
yes it's uncomfortable but this is what
I want yeah right and then so we go
through these waves of comfort and
change comfort and change and that's
just like the waves of life every
morning when you wake up you have let's
say let's say it's 10 attention units if
you're using two or three or four or
five or six of them on one unit an
attention unit is your your ability to
stay focused on and your ability to stay
focused
um is happening at the conscious and
non-conscious level so if you're
processing stuff in the back of your
mind of something you're angry at
something you're mad at something that's
stressing out that or you don't have
enough money or you don't have the right
relationships or the contacts whatever
if you're stressing out about that stuff
and that's eating up your attention
units that's like having your computer
okay using up most of its energy in
what's behind that you're not using and
we all have a certain amount of
attention units every day and so one of
the things that you asked me before that
I can come back on the rituals is is
using the attention units in a way that
is highly highly productive versus yeah
wasting a lot of time and so my ritual
we started earlier I just remembered
that is you know wake up meditation
exercise
plant-based protein smoothie followed by
reviewing my goals every day you review
every day five minutes the goals for the
day the month every year everything I
review my overarching goals I could do
that fairly quickly because that's my
longer range goals I can review the
emotions that I want because I'm
committed to having those emotions every
day and feeling a certain way every day
and then I take a look at from you know
you know five years out three years one
year 90 days 60 days to today wow and so
I just review it and what happens the
paper laminated and on my computer
really yeah and I have it in a in a
booklet also so when I travel it's
really easy do you have it with you
right no no it's it's a it's a pretty
big it's like a little manual you have
to send me a photo so I can see it yeah
I'll send you just call my exceptional
life blueprint I like it and um and so
the the question many people may ask is
why why would you do that well because
you're having 35 to 50 000 thoughts a
day right and your brain isn't certain
like what's really important what's not
but if you instruct your brain that
something is really important whether
it's something you don't want or
something you do it will actually pay
attention to you right so by priming my
brain early every day here is what I
want you to focus on here are the
emotions I want you to express through
me here's the behaviors that I need to
take then I am on a daily basis setting
the course for what I want my brain to
focus on I am cognitively priming the
pump and if I do it one day that's great
if I do it 60 days a hundred days my
brain goes hey I'm just going to make
this automatic because I want to
conserve energy right right I'm just
going to make it automatic so not only
will you focus on it consciously I'm
just going to make everything happen
behind the scenes to help help you see
think and feel things that are congruent
with what you're trading your life for
and what you want to achieve so I'm just
using the system better on my my epitase
he lived he loved he gave he had fun
I always thought that if there's a way
that I could somehow use my life in a
way that I can make somebody else's life
a little bit easier to live either
through knowledge or understanding or
love or a process
then my life's been worthwhile it's
always fun to me I just want to make a
difference and I'm one of the people
that doesn't believe that there's
anything wrong in the world everything's
unfolding exactly as it should there are
many things not to my taste that I don't
understand but I just want to make the
journey as good as I can for as many
people as I can there was actually a
very very big mistake in the movie The
Secret okay and in the movie The Secret
the
story that was told was that all you
have to do is think
believe in your heart and you'll achieve
it's not true
there's a lot of people who think
wonderful great thoughts they believe
that I deserve this and I can have this
but they don't do one thing
and this is what causes their problem
you know what that one thing is I want
to know they don't take consistent
action every day
so in the secret they didn't talk about
you have to do the right things in the
right order at the right time
and they let a lot of people to believe
that all you have to do is think about
it just think about it well I've never
met
a monk
in a monastery who's been praying to
make money and through the ceiling a
safe Falls with a million dollars I've
never met that yet
and but I have met a lot of people who
think and believe and then they learn
what they need to learn they upgrade
their knowledge and their skills they
overcome their fears they overcome their
doubts they overcome their lack of
confidence they overcome the lack of
certainty and they take action anyway
and then little by little
things start to happen for them they
achieve the results and we call that the
law of Goya
g-o-y-a get off your
Law of Attraction uh it's my favorite
Law of Attraction and law of Goya
together that's what works when it comes
to the you know the uh the problems that
come up every day I mean it's it's like
weather it's sunny for a little bit it's
raining it's hailing it's windy it's not
that's life and and that goes back to
where we started a little bit earlier
about the frames is if you expect things
to always be great you're delusional if
you expect things to always be bad
and so it's a matter of learning the
frames and how do you frame stuff so
even when you know I was going through
this challenging challenging times on a
lot of fronts
um the frame was still good we are all
creatures of a habit because habits run
their themselves their subconscious
programs just run themselves most people
don't take the time to become aware what
are my empowering habits what am I
disempowering habits and then the next
question is well how do I release this
one and how do I strengthen this one or
create a whole new one
and what we're looking to do is build
empowering habits that then run run
their course when somebody tells me
they've done everything
usually they've done everything that
they're aware of doing
but there has to be something if we go
back to some brain research and some
brain
Neuroscience findings there's a part of
the brain
that chooses the goal that we want to
achieve and that's in the conscious part
of the brain and that's responsive about
two to four percent of what you see and
what you do yeah that's called the
explicit memory system or the
declarative part of the brain I can
declare so I'll give you an example I
could read a book yeah and 10 minutes
later I could tell you what I've read in
the book I can declare everything that's
in the book I can tell you you know what
this is a great book I'm so excited I'm
so motivated and I'm gonna make a
million dollars
but if
at least if at the implicit level at the
beneath the conscious mind at the
implicit level in secret they say
I don't know if I'm good enough
I don't know if I'm smart enough I don't
know if I deserve to make a million
dollars I don't have the right knowledge
I didn't go to college I'm male I'm
female I'm too young I'm too old if
there's a disconnect
between the implicit the part of our
brains that's the real you and me this
hidden part of our self-image if there
is a
contradiction
between my goal and even what I've
learned and what I secretly believe to
be true by myself if there isn't the
coherence between the two the hidden
self-image will always win
so one of the most important things is
to create what I call is neural
coherence or coherence in the brain and
the best way to think about coherence in
their brains imagine if
you know you go to listen to a band rock
and roll band jazz band a classical Band
Whatever and every player okay or every
musician is playing the music but not in
harmony
yeah new style you're never gonna have a
beautiful Symphony
so the way our brain works is if we
don't have the symphony at the different
parts of the brain we'll do some good
things and some good actions and then
we'll do some things that will take away
from that
and so what we want to have is is
coherence
get the brain the implicit and the
explicit part of the brain coherence
playing together
in harmony then moves the body into
action consistently
now we have flow now we have a way for
us to take our ideas
and take action consistently to achieve
results an hour our day to upgrade your
mindset and your skill set one hour a
day is all you need to set aside to
upgrade your beliefs your habits your
attitude your perceptions your emotional
management and upgrade the skills that
you need in order to play at the next
level of success so if you calculate one
hour a day is 365 hours in a year
that equals nine 40 hour weeks nine 40
hour weeks after one year you're really
good after two years you're really
really good after three four five six
years of doing this every day just
upgrading your Knowledge and Skills with
expert information and knowledge and and
strategies and tactics you are in a
whole different place in your life so
invest one hour a day to upgrade your
mindset and your skill set so your
action set what you need to do
becomes automatic instead of something
you have to consciously try to do every
day because mindset plus skill set plus
action set equals your results you know
I uh I've just come through a really
challenging time I was in business with
one of my very best friends of 30 years
and we started a company together in two
thousand and six or so
and he ended up with severe diabetes and
had a stroke and had a heart attack and
it went you know everything just went on
a hand basket lost lots of money lots of
employees we had about 70 plus employees
who let them go close the company down I
had friends of mine who put two million
dollars into the deal I put a couple
million dollars into the deal and it was
you know all my intellectual property
that developed over 60 years was
basically held up in a legal lawsuit
that I had with one of my shareholders
and investors and it was a very
challenging time as as you know
reputation IP started from scratch
assets yeah lots so it was challenging
very very challenging time and uh
fortunately because of you know my
meditative practices staying staying
aware of what is not buying too much
into that I just you know started
building a new company over the last
four years and I've got you know 30
amazing team members now at a company of
neurogym my relationship my wife is
great my kids are us and my health has
never been better I became vegan about
five years ago stopped drinking alcohol
seven years ago gave up sugar about
three weeks ago
let me know how long you keep it up I
made a decision now it's a year so yeah
one year no sweets yeah no refined sugar
if it happens to be if there happens to
be honey on uh you know on something
then a little bit's fine but no refined
sugar no cookies no cakes no chocolate
bars no soft drinks nothing well right
now I don't have any Cravings whatsoever
zero wait till the holidays it's true
you know what I just came back from
Montreal and and I was there for the
holidays and the dessert table was about
as big as this and I just said no and a
week before actually four days before
that I was in Las Vegas at Encore at the
buffet and I actually took a video of
everything that was there and I said now
what I did beforehand is I pre-committed
when I before I went to Las Vegas and
now when I go to the buffet here's what
I will do when I go to this restaurant
here's what I would decide pre-committed
in advance played it over in my mind 10
15 20 times put myself in the situation
in my mind and then when I was there it
was it was easy breezy because I'd done
it you visualize 10 20 30 times so I did
that and so when I went to Montreal
usually I go to Montreal and all goes to
lose my mother you know is always in
every day not anymore my sister's taking
over oh yeah so the uh you know the food
that's there and um and the desserts
that are there breakfast in there too I
love poutine oh yeah yeah dessert but
the desserts for me is was the hardest
part but it was like easy breezy I own
my feelings and my emotions and my
results
I own my feelings my emotions and my
results I learned how to be responsible
to be able to respond to emotions that
are unpleasant to feelings that are you
know yucky I learned that whatever was
happening in my world
I had the ability to upgrade my skill so
that I can use everything that happens
in a way that serves me as opposed to a
way that hurts me or moves me back any
conflicts that you are experiencing is
going to create neural dissonance in
your brain it's just going to create
chaos in your brain and so if you take
it out of your head and you put it on a
sheet of paper you can look at it and
now you're one step removed from what's
happening in your brain and so the more
you can be in coherence it's the
equivalent of being part of a band
that's in harmony that every player is
just like oh man this just sounds so
good well the more you can be in
coherence the more you're going to be in
flow and the more you're going to take
action the more chaos there is in the
brain neural chaos whether it's because
of emotions you're lacking something
this conflict there's resistance the
more you can get it out into the in
front of you and open and say well
what's causing this
the easier it is for that Einstein brain
to say okay maybe I could do this maybe
I could do that but I can also call a
friend or a mentor or a coach or I can
research it there is
that business is easy
and I have a lot of clients of mine for
example that are there are doctors and
lawyers and professionals that have an
expertise
in a certain area
but nobody's ever taught them about
Finance about legal if they're not a
lawyer about marketing about sales about
technology about operations About
Management
and being an entrepreneur is like
solving a Rubik's Cube yes I see that
right so you can have the two by two
with two colors you know it's easy
if you want a little bit bigger business
that's three by three there's more
combinations and more things that need
to be considered
four by four now has billions of
different moves just four by fours
billions of different possibilities wow
when you get to the eight by eight or 16
by 16 Rubik's Cube
there's quintillions of possible moves
that you can make
so building a business is all about
recognizing patterns and knowing which
move to make at the right time and
there's four options that you have one
is do it yourself and try and figure it
out two is get help
three get it done for you or four don't
do it a lot of people ask me about money
all the time it's one of the things we
teach people how to do is grow their
businesses and how to make more money
and they say well you know I want to
make more money
I said well in order to make more money
first you have to believe that you can
right then you have to believe you
deserve it
then you have to make sure that you have
something that you can earn money with
so it's either going to be your ideas
you want to you can sell your ideas
yeah like a trainer you can sell your
time you can sell your products you can
sell your services which means that you
have to have some skill
or you have to have somebody else who
can do it for you you have to see your
skill right well you have to either see
your skill or determine what skills are
needed okay and if you don't have it get
somebody else who has it to help you and
so when when somebody tells me I want to
make more money I say them let's say we
have a pen I don't have a pen here but
if we had a pen yes and we wanted to
make money
we could go and find somebody who wants
to buy this pen yeah right now
and how much is somebody willing to pay
for the pen
well if the pen is worth a dollar
maybe you can get a dollar for it but
what about finding somebody who needs it
because they have to sign a contract
that's due in 10 minutes
that person might pay a hundred dollars
for that pin yeah so our job is to take
you know our skills our knowledge our
products our services our abilities
and to be able to present it to people
who need it and want it in exchange for
money because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want another amazing John
ask for video check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe I'll see you there